[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this is a difficult thing that we're
doing it's a hard thing it's a new thing
and you know I'd hope that you cheer us
on cheer us on
foreign
[Music]
for future space flight you know I think
it's another step towards the Stars
Elon Musk is not your average Tech
billionaire he's one of the most
intriguing entrepreneurs in business
today The Man Behind PayPal is taking on
the giant of the Aerospace and motor
Industries along with the oil
corporations the energy utility
companies and winning
Elon Musk is a Visionary someone who
comes along perhaps
a century
enjoying the way we function and the way
we look at the world
back then people were still afraid to
buy books online so putting together a
financial services Suite on the internet
was a rather revolutionary idea and that
company turned out to be PayPal the
online payment service it's one thing to
run a company that's worth a billion
dollars Elon Musk has four my personal
ideology is kind of split right now
between trying to be helpful on earth
related stuff which is sustainable
energy and then trying to advance space
technology so we can establish a
self-sustaining City on Mars
from AI to disrupting the car industry
to Solar City I mean how many other
people can say I have my home rocket
company not many
in terms of space elon's completely
changed how we think about everything
when you look at what SpaceX has done
with their reusable Rockets we are
seeing science fiction of the 1950s
coming to life Rockets land as they
always Were Meant to do it's really
trying to land on a closer step there
astonishingly difficult so Mars does
reckon I am very convinced this is going
to happen in my lifetime
you look at Tesla alone has changed the
way the automobiles will be forever in
the future he has truly broken down the
wall that was impossible to break and
now we're in a situation where all of
the big car companies are switching
massively to electric cars and that is a
revolution done by one man
he's almost like a
there's a lot more
so I think we just get to watch and be
excited and see what comes next
a lot of people think that successful
entrepreneurs or just happen to be in
the right place at the right time with
the right product or right service
that's untrue
why are they not content with 25 million
when they sell the first company then go
into a second company for another 50
million or a third company where they
fail and go into another one serial
entrepreneurs
are driven
they're psychologically driven and it's
usually to do with something in their
childhood
Elon Reeve musk was born in Pretoria in
1971. the son of a Canadian mother and
South African father
Elan grew up in South
Herald upbringing he has said that you
know he was he was raised basically by
books and occasionally nannies
his mother and father have two other
kids there he has a younger brother and
sister Kimball and Tosca but it seemed
like Elon didn't have a lot of adult
supervision he said that he was
basically out there building explosives
and learning about conduction with very
little supervision
he had a passion for engineering and
obviously physics and the Sciences as
well
musk attended waterkloof primary school
and after his parents divorced
nine-year-old Elon went to live with his
father
Elon at one stage in his childhood after
his parents divorced says that he felt
sorry for his dad living by himself so
he opted to go and live with his dad
that he later called a huge mistake he's
been on record saying he didn't have a
great relationship with his father he's
notably said some really really hard
things about his dad it sounds like it
was a really awful situation
father was an engineer and Elon says
that a lot of his engineering now came
from his father and his father had some
issues according to Elon but what he did
have was a very incisive engineering
background as disturbing as elon's
relationship with his dad seemed to be
elon's relationship with his mother
appears to be very good and went from
strength to strength I think his mother
is probably the ultimate Optimist she's
lovely she's really something
oh from The New York Times there's May
it's great I've been modeling for 50
years so
um you just have to just keep on going
and be nice and available and be
surprised when you suddenly become
mother of the bride and then grandmother
elon's mum has been very supportive of
him over the years she's constantly
outspoken on Twitter and telling us all
the wonders of Elon and she's clearly
very proud of him May musk is an
incredible woman at something like 69
she's called an It Girl by Vanity Fair
she's an in-demand model who's doing
campaigns for big Major Brands all over
the world she is one of the most
glamorous older women you will ever see
despite the fact that Elon says he tried
repeatedly again and again and again to
try and repair his relationship with his
father at this stage he's just given up
because he doesn't believe his dad is
capable of change he's talked openly
about how as a child he spent a lot of
time alone he says he can still remember
the sound of an empty house footsteps
far off in the distance and he never
ever wanted that again
my own view is the really Stellar
entrepreneurs
their life experiences particularly in
childhood are the determinant of their
success later on if you look at their
Early Childhood experiences you will
find a number of Adverse Events
substantial Adverse Events like school
bullying or being rejected these events
drive you you now need to prove
something you want to gain control of a
world again you didn't have control of
when you were younger and moving toward
a top job being an entrepreneur being a
CEO gives you power gives you strength
gives you control the thing they never
had when they were younger so I think
that's a driving force in many
entrepreneurs
foreign musk attended bryanston High
School in Pretoria where he thrived
academically
he had quite a tough upbringing there
are some reports of bullying as well you
know any child that shows that sort of
intellect and interesting might come
under the the glare of the bullies
because even hospitalized after one
particular fight
he was a nerd he was bullied at school
it was one point he was even knocked
unconscious you know it wasn't obvious
that he was a marketing genius at that
point
Elon took on wrestling classes and a bit
of Judo in attempt to compensate with a
bit of added physicality and then he
grew up a little bit got a growth spurt
got a bit taller and and really took the
bully's head on
after spending three years at bryanston
high Elon attended Pretoria high school
for boys
Elon attended boys are from 1986 until
1988 which is the year he matriculated
he excelled in science and he also
excelled in computer studies he in fact
got a distinction for both science and
computer studies in 1988.
as I do recall his grades because I have
them in my mark book and he was
definitely top of the science class
I've taught many boys over the years and
Elon did stick in my mind you know I
can't tell you where every boy SAT but I
can remember Elon sitting at the back of
the classroom getting on with his work
he wasn't one of the boys that wanted
attention all the time we always take a
lot of pride in all of the boys but from
a personal point of view having taught
to Elon science
I'd like to think that I made a small
input in these formative years I've read
he would like to go to Mars I'm hoping
he'll do that a lot sooner but Star Trek
style saying can invite me there
[Music]
Elon Musk was always different his
entrepreneurial Ventures started early
in 1984 a science fiction inspired Tech
success gave a hint of his future when
he sold his first commercial software
he started working on computers at the
age of 10 working very hard on it and
being very clever and developing
programs
he develops a video game called Blaster
he famously sold this to a PC Magazine
for five hundred dollars Elon was asked
about what sets him apart from other
people and he himself said there were
things that were very obvious to him
growing up that other people didn't
understand how conduction Works how
light and wires make a light switch go
on things that to him were immediately
clear and obvious whereas other people
didn't automatically especially when
they're like 14 understand what was
going on you played a lot of Chess and
as a result of that was always sort of
thinking ahead in chess you play to
think moves ahead so even when he was
younger he was looking at ideas for what
might make a good business in the short
term and then what could be part of a
grand plan further on
okay
after graduating from high school musk
briefly attended the University of
Pretoria before deciding to leave South
Africa the story of Elon musk's wealth
and his Rises is tied up in part with
the American dream it was always
ingrained him that South Africa wasn't
where he was going to achieve the
Ambitions he had he wanted to be in
America he wanted to be part of that
scene initially he couldn't go directly
to America so actually had to go through
Canada
Elon spent two years studying at Queen's
University in Ontario
he funded his own degrees in Canada and
the US by getting scholarships and
working part-time so he didn't have a
huge amount of money behind him he has a
famous university paper where he talks
about wanting to conquer different areas
of the world and those included the
Internet space exploration solar energy
artificial intelligence and brain
learning interfaces as well
they met at University her name was
Justine she was absolutely beautiful and
on their first date they were supposed
to go out for ice cream she actually
said yes and then basically ditched him
and went off to do some studying instead
he didn't take no for an answer he
pursued her he continued to pursue her
and even after Elon left the university
he attended with Justine and moved to
Wharton business school he still sent
her roses regularly when Elon Musk is
interested in you I think he comes on
like a steam train or an electric steam
train perhaps but Elon Musk is
Unstoppable he sees what he wants and he
does everything he needs to do to get it
he's like that in business and he's like
that in love
having completed degrees in business and
physics in 1995 musk abandoned a PhD at
Stanford and headed for Silicon Valley
he famously dropped out of his third
degree at Stanford University in
California after just two days he
launched a company with his brother
Kimball called zip2 and it was
effectively a form of online Yellow
Pages that they sold to newspapers at
the time and he struck lucky when the
company was bought they actually ended
up selling it to Compaq for about 307
million dollars when he was only 27
years old he made about 22 million
dollars back then which is wonderful an
awful lot of money but in typical Elon
style he recycled half of that into his
next venture and which eventually ended
up becoming a PayPal
having disrupted the traditional paper
advertising industry with zip2 musk's
next venture took on the Global
Financial Market
Services business so it sounds sort of
archaic now but back at the time putting
together a financial services Suite on
the internet was a rather revolutionary
idea
he had one internet win under his belt
so it was not especially challenging to
bring on new Engineers or new business
people who wanted to work on something
that seemed very exciting and was
someone who had already won already once
so that was a big feather in his cap it
was I think more challenging to persuade
outside investors that that it was a
good idea because they were not swayed
by one win it was not enough to buy
public opinion in Silicon Valley the
jury was still sort of out on whether he
was genius or crazy or just big ego or
how it was all going to play out but he
invested 10 or 12 million dollars of his
own money into x.com so we didn't need a
whole lot of money right off the bat we
sort of took care of all of that
musk was revolutionary in his strategy
at x.com gifting new customers cash
rewards and creating peer-to-peer
Payment Systems my initial Impressions
were just that he was very focused and
very passionate on what he was about to
do
seemed very clear early on that Elon was
not playing by the standard Book of Life
or business or anything else so
I was just going to be along for the
ride
at the beginning Elon wasn't easy to
read at all mostly because he just had
no idea how he was going to react to
anything I had no experience with
someone who thought the way that he did
or talked the way that he did or had as
much confidence about what he was doing
and in himself as he did that was so
foreign to me as someone who grew up in
Iowa
or maybe it's foreign to everyone I
don't know
PayPal was voted one of the 10 worst
business ideas in 1999. Elon Musk was
instrumental in the company's focus on a
global payment system which would change
the course of the internet people
probably know him mostly from PayPal
that was when he really first came to
public Consciousness PayPal was how are
we going to turn finances into an online
transaction how are we going to make it
easy how are we going to make it more
efficient sounds sort of obvious now but
back then people were still afraid to
buy books online so asking them to put
all their financial data in one place
was not a solid proposition
the goal of the company that we were
building was always trying to do
something very positive for Humanity and
he was thinking about space and solar
panels and all of that way back then so
we knew that this was sort of a stepping
stone on the way to grander dreams
PayPal soon became the online payment
system of choice from a few thousand
users multiplying to more than a million
within months
the person-to-person payment side of
things took off so quickly that we were
gaining traction like crazy and then the
online auction Market took hold of it
and it blew up into this huge thing and
we were adding tens of thousands of new
accounts every day which at the time was
fairly unprecedented and Elon was very
Hands-On in all aspects of the company
it was his money after all that we were
all playing with so I think when it's
your money on the table you have it's in
your best interest to be very involved
in all the details
every day was a new sort of fire right
every day something was burning down
that needed to be addressed we had a
customer service nightmare where soon
after launching the service we had
thousands and thousands of emails in the
queue because people didn't understand
again the early days of the internet
they didn't understand how to get their
money out and so they would freak out
and call in or email like 12 different
times so we had two million emails in
the queue and we only had 10 customer
service people dedicated to dealing with
that and so we really had no idea what
we were going to do customer service was
enormously expensive in California and
so I said you know this is going to
sound crazy but I have a huge extended
family in the midwest I could train them
all to do customer service at home Elon
laughed at first and then a couple of
hours later came back and said all right
get on a plane so I went out and taught
10 of my family members how to do
customer service from home and then my
sister ended up hiring 12 stay-at-home
parents in a small town in Nebraska who
started all working from home and they
were so good that we ended up building
customer service center in Omaha
Nebraska which now employs 1800 people
and that turned out fantastic we went
from zero to a hundred people in six
weeks out in Omaha and that was
probably the most challenging thing but
we're a little short of options so
by his passion
ISM determination and a heroic work
ethic
musk has succeeded in markets that were
previously considered impossible to
conquer
he's always had higher expectations for
himself than he did for other people so
he pushed himself very very hard there's
a lot of pressure on him because he has
a lot of expectations a lot of
responsibility to his shareholders to
the capital that he has sourced to his
staff his colleagues so there's a lot of
Demands so you can't just say you know
what this is all good and great I'm just
going to take six months off you know
why because I've got 20 billion so it's
okay I no it doesn't work like that
guys the stakes get higher and the more
people that get involved there's more
pressure on that front but I think that
he looks at it and
turns away
what drives Elon what pushes him I don't
get it but he's making changes in the
world because he doesn't ever stop and
rest he just keeps going Elon Musk is
famous for his work ethic which is
non-stop I think ESO has two modes you
know stop them go he works around the
clock and he expects everyone else to do
the same Elon was up at all hours of the
night working he would send emails at
midnight or 1 or 2 A.M and just be very
focused on some problem that we were
trying to solve if you hear stories from
SpaceX in the early days people were
really struggling to keep Pace with him
but that's how he works and if you can't
keep base you're out the door
I thought he was a good boss I'm sort of
Infamous now that he runs through PR
people very quickly but at that time I
thought I was just going to be like a
normal PR person and so Elon wasn't
really going to have any of that
he expected a lot of his people but we
all expected a lot of each other I mean
that's how you get it done
the culture of startups
the expectation is that everybody is
working all the time you get there at
nine or ten in the morning and not leave
until nine or ten or maybe after that at
night and Elon was definitely working
until midnight every night that was just
what we did and it was exciting I rarely
did anyone complain about that kind of
thing because you really felt like you
were changing the world
by the year 2000 musk had married
Justine Wilson he was always pining for
Justine who was still in Canada at that
point and so it was lovely when she came
down the couple did suffer a tragedy
very early on their baby boy was 10
weeks old Nevada when he died suddenly
of Sids it was beyond difficult for both
of them to cope with Justine immediately
sought IVF and fertility help and went
on to have five boys one set of triplets
and one set of twin boys so very quickly
they went from having no children to
having five Justine he's written
extensively about how it caused a strain
in the marriage as it might do as it
would do but this tragic event of losing
their infant son unfortunately didn't
draw the couple closer but rather was
the beginning perhaps of what ultimately
would pull them apart
as PayPal flourished boardroom troubles
dogged Musk
an internal disagreement with the board
resulted in Elon being ousted from his
own company there was a time when Peter
Thiel and Elon were co-ceos at PayPal
but there were certain differences in
opinion about the technology and The
Branding of the company that led to the
vote of no confidence to oust Elon and
Elon unfortunately was in
South Africa I had just spoken with him
on the phone that day and he's like how
bad is it I'm like oh it's not that bad
and then that night I went home and I
was laying in bed and I started
realizing started putting together all
the pieces of who I'd seen in the office
and what was happening and and at about
10 30 at night I sat straight up in bed
and thought I'm sure I said some swear
word at the ceiling and it got up and I
went back in the office and sure enough
everybody was there and that was when
they were doing it they were talking to
the board on the phone and ousting him
and I tried to call Elon and he was on a
plane and I couldn't get him I couldn't
get him until the morning and by then it
was too late it was already done
I'm sure there was quite a bit of
unhappiness early on but he really
handled it marvelously
musk left PayPal but as the largest
shareholder remained in an advisory role
his next windfall arrived in 2002 when
eBay bought PayPal leaving him wealthy
beyond belief
that was where Elon started to make some
serious money he cashed in about 165
million dollars wonderful what was
amazing is he plowed almost all of it
into these new business ventures he
didn't put any aside for himself didn't
think of sort of personal gain in the
short term at least a lot of us would
have just retired he made the money in
PayPal he could have just stopped and
you know bought a place in the south of
France and and said I'm retiring I'm 28
and be done but he ended up starting
three other billion dollar companies
it took 100 million and put it into
SpaceX 70 million ends up going to Tesla
and about 10 million going to Solar City
most people say 165 million I'm set for
life that's it where is the beach let's
go
not Elon and I have a lot of respect for
that
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Elon
Musk
in 2001 Elon established the musk
Foundation delivering solar energy
systems to areas of the world struck by
natural disasters he also pledged to
give away at least half of his wealth to
philanthropy
a lot of people think that entrepreneurs
are driven by money and that's why
they're serious entrepreneurs they want
to make more and more really after you
make 50 million you need to earn more
money not really that's not a good
driver
they're not driven by money at all
he's aware of it no doubt I mean if
you've got 20 billion floating around
I'm sure you would have noticed but I
don't think that's the main driver for
him I really don't I think he's got a
bigger Vision Beyond this little thing
called called money but money helps him
execute the dream so it is a necessary
thing
it's certainly not the pursuit of money
at this point
I think he realized we're here and it's
more interesting to spend time doing
something that you find meaningful in
your heart and that's what he's doing
it's almost like a drug
when you've done one successful thing
you want to do the other one you want to
come up with a new vision you keep
learning it's just a way of being you'll
be bought on the beach
it has to be a very big world-changing
goal for him to get up in the morning
that's just the way he's wired so I
don't expect that to stop
I think it actually is going to make a
difference to the world if we transition
to sustainable transport sooner rather
than later
we're not doing this because we thought
it was like a way to get rich or
anything like I said I thought I thought
maybe 10 chance of success at the
beginning I thought it would just lose
all my money
um it almost did so it's not like it was
you know that was you're very close to
losing everything
Falcon 9 has cleared the tower
having conquered cyberspace musk's next
mission would focus on outer space in
2002 he launched one of the most
revolutionary businesses of our time
focused on shaking up the space industry
the pivotal breakthrough that's
necessary to make life multi-planetary
is a fully and rapidly reusable orbit
class rocket this is a very difficult
thing to do because we live on a planet
where that is just barely possible in
the last 12 months or so I've come to
conclusion that it can be solved and and
I think SpaceX is going to try to do it
we could fail I'm not saying we we're a
certain of success here but we're going
to try to do it he'd already been
talking about energy and transportation
and space I was like why space he's like
space is cool
right
no one thought he could do what he's
done when he first set out to achieve
his goals I mean this random South
African coming along in the 2000s and
saying he wants to build a rocket that
can land itself back on the ground can
take things to orbit for 10 times
cheaper than anyone else he was laughed
at the room at most places they kind of
ignored him at first and then he kind of
put his money where his mouth was
literally he famously went to Russia
once to try and buy some rocket engines
off their members yeah laughed out of
the country basically by their Engineers
so he came out to the US and he built
his own rocket
we were still used to NASA space equals
NASA but when Elon Musk started to
experiment with these new rockets we
realized that Elon Musk and SpaceX is a
serious space player
everything looking good for the
beginning of today's space walking tasks
the first three SpaceX launches failed
which sparked skepticism in many
investors
vehicle on course on track
[Music]
appear to have had a
launch vehicle failure
unit is deaf is definitely difficult
and I think we forget that some times we
launches and landings as a routine it's
a huge amount of energy and dangerous
substances and that work is very hard
look where we are today
the critics have been silenced
just one year after founding SpaceX musk
invested in Tesla Motors an electric car
manufacturer aiming to produce a power
packed zero polluting car
over the next several years Tesla would
take the lead in a niche market
our goal was to really try to create the
best car in the world in order to show
that an electric car can be the best car
in the world
a lot of people have this perception
that electric cars are compromised that
there are issues with electric cars and
that if you buy electric it's because
you have some sort of electric fetish
what I think is incredibly important is
to break that perception and show that
indeed the electric car can be better
than any gasoline car cars were always a
big deal you had that F1 McLaren show up
very early on in the x.com days and
there was a Jaguar very soon after that
and he liked them all very much anything
that was rare expensive and cool
if you look at the revolution that's
almost Upon Us in electric cars Tesla
was there first
there's been various attempts to
Bringing electric cars which have failed
because big car Giants didn't want them
to succeed
Elon knew nothing about electric cars
when he started out but recognized that
there was a problem there that needed to
be solved and it's just bulldozed his
way through it
I'm really excited by the fact that
we've got a zero emission sports car
that can go head to head with a Ferrari
and a Porsche and win
this is what's truly disruptive a tech
guy coming into the car space Elon
doesn't look it as a car it's a piece of
software with a little bit of Hardware
attached to it the driving experience in
a Tesla everybody is raving about it it
was awesome it was unbelievable the
acceleration was out of this world like
a roller coaster I felt like I was going
to fly or something it's quick it's
silent but also with Teslas it's the
technology the fact that they update
themselves I had a Tesla for a while and
I'll come out in the morning software
update as your phone does and you get
the stuff on your car that you didn't
have the previous night you could
actually move your Tesla out of a
parking spot with your smartphone so
it's just incredible for somebody who's
a car fan and a tech fan then Teslas
really do tick a lot of boxes
the future is Electric in the future we
won't be filling up for petrol Elon has
understood that for a decade already
you're seeing countries across Europe
France uh the UK all saying they're
going to ban the sale of petrol cars in
the next 10 20 years and that's pretty
much thanks to Tesla
in the face of massively declining oil
prices I think it actually becomes more
urgent that the auto manufacturers
transition to electric and put a huge
amount of effort behind their electric
vehicle programs what's amazing is how
the rest of the Auto industry is sort of
following they had this lithium-ion cell
technology that other companies really
couldn't match there isn't a car company
in the world who isn't looking at an
electric vehicle there's probably not a
car company in the world who hasn't
taken a Tesla apart to see what what's
going on underneath it Tesla we've open
sourced our patents so we're trying to
be as helpful as possible for the Advent
of electric vehicles we've also said
that our supercharged Network we're
happy to have other car makers use that
Network we're really doing doing
everything we can to accelerate the
Advent of sustainable cars
I mean now we know that GM and Land
Rover have said they're going to start
doing electric cars in the near future
just electric cars there's so many
things that Tesla has done first which
has got every other car maker around the
planet looking thinking yeah we've got
to do it like that haven't we the
fundamental problem is the rules today
concerned people to create carbon
and this is madness and whatever you
incent will happen we need to send a
clear message to the negotiating teams
into the politicians that this time
there needs to be significant change
an essential part of Elon musk's tale of
Triumph is how close he came to complete
Disaster by his own admission 2008 was
the worst year of his life
his companies were battered by the
economic meltdown
three failed launches left SpaceX
hanging in the balance and Tesla was on
the verge of bankruptcy
Elon was widely assumed to be finished
he certainly has his ups and downs and
believe me it has been lots of ups and
downs he seems to have the media on his
back almost permanently but that seems
to be the price of success in the early
years it really came down to a knife
edge as to whether or not SpaceX was
going to make it whether or not it was
going to
to go bankrupt he was having to allocate
resources and money between Tesla and
SpaceX in order to keep them going and
it came down to having to borrow money
from friends and family and bear in mind
this is a man who made Millions offer
offer a software sale earlier Elon Musk
he's had plenty of failures failed
rocket launches and you have to go
through this learning curve with the
early rockets and all of that he didn't
seem to understand that the chances were
they were going to blow up but sometimes
through your greatest failure you make
your greatest steps forward
he just keeps going he keeps pushing the
boat out it is just an insatiable
appetite to just keep going whatever
happens yes is yes
maybe is yes and I know it's just a
delayed yes there were a million places
along the way where he could have
stopped or been derailed or decided to
go by that island and just sit on it but
he didn't
they're Risk Takers they love it they
live to be on the knife edge failure is
expected entrepreneurs don't expect
necessary to see it all the time which
is a characteristic that makes them
successful because when they do fail and
all entrepreneurs do because they take
risks
they just brush it off they have this
phenomenal bounce back Factor
unlike other people who get absorbed by
the failure and get stymied and they
can't do anything else for a while he
can cope with failure and to be able to
bounce back and then go into another
venture without blinking an eye
is what it's all about
[Music]
with his companies on the brink of
collapse Doom was averted at the last
minute
Tesla was saved by investors
SpaceX was awarded a 1.6 billion dollar
NASA contract
asex team is incredible they are really
pushing the boundaries in terms of where
we're going forward with exploration I
think humans are naturally driven to do
this and this is really the beginning I
think of human beings leaving low earth
orbit I certainly plan on being around
to see that
in 2010 Elon Musk is Dragon spacecraft
to the International Space Station
SpaceX became the first company to dock
a private spacecraft with the ISS which
was at the time amazing
this is Mission Control Houston official
hatch opening time for the SpaceX Dragon
spacecraft
every bit of adrenaline in my body
released at that point it serves this
extremely intense moment anything could
have gone wrong and everything went
right fortunately so I I felt I feel
very lucky
Don Pettit giving the thumbs up there as
well as the rest of the crew
Elon Musk is developing a track record
of delivering on what he says he will
so he already has developed reusable
Rockets he is supplying the space
station the next stage will be to have
versions of his Dragon spacecraft that
are human rated so he is actually
delivering on his promise
[Music]
after his marriage to Justine had
unraveled into divorce musk began dating
British actress Tallulah Riley
according to Justine her divorce was
finalized and six weeks later she found
out Elon was married to someone else it
was an extremely quick quoting he met
her quarter and then asked her to marry
they went on to have a very wonderful
but also very tempestuous relationship
they married they divorced they
remarried they announced a divorce and
they called off the divorce and then
they put the divorce back on it's very
difficult to keep track of Elon and
tallulah's ups and downs they ended
things in a very amicable fashion and
even now Tallulah says Never Never Say
Never they could still end up back
together again
foreign
over the next several years Tesla would
take the lead in the electric car market
under elon's leadership the company is
heralded as the Great American Auto
industry success story of the century
I just learned uh just hope that the
total number of orders for the model 3
in the past 24 hours has now passed 150
000.
is concerns about climate change and
sustainability is what's behind all of
this push towards an electric car not
just a fancy Tesla but also a mid-range
car that for 35 000 or less that
everybody can drive when the model 3
which launched there were some like 400
000 people who put money down that's
unheard of in the car industry you might
have some waiting lists but to to wait
that long for a relatively affordable
car is something we haven't seen before
you can see the line has been building
up ever since we got here so it's like a
never-ending line and some Taurus
actually came up to me and asked what
this was and then I said it was Tesla
and they knew about it
Tesla famously doesn't advertise I don't
think it needs to there's such a buzz
about the brand
things are on track to be able to meet
the model 3 starter production timing in
the middle of next year
and uh
really excited about what's happening
Tesla's value is something that has a
lot of people scratching their heads the
fact that it's a company that's not
making money but yet it has a huge value
if you look at the revenues to market
cap of the car maker Honda and the value
to revenue on Tesla Honda would be
trading at about 0.5 times Tesla would
be trading about 7.4 times today so
Tesla is obviously valued a lot more
given the little Revenue that it
produces why because there's a lot of
Goodwill in the stock and that's because
Elon has a fan club in the investment
community and that access to Capital
that Goodwill that's Brands if you like
is wonderful feeling because that does
allow him to get on with other things
such as the boring company or his AI
Ambitions or whatever else crazy
Frontier driven ideas he comes up with
next
the reputation Tesla has is as much to
do with the product as the the guy
that's running the company frankly if
the cars weren't any good people
wouldn't buy them but but they are good
they are technology leaders and that's
what really gets the following the fact
that there's a guy like heat on running
the company as well is the icing on the
cape the general public really
appreciate that sort of candid approach
to how he's running his companies what
keeps me intrigued about musk is if you
look closely you can see his signature
in the products that he makes so for
example the Tesla sound system goes up
to 11 it's a reference to spinal tap
the ludicrous mode the warp speed that
you get on the screen when you unlock an
Easter egg for extra performance it's
those little details that car companies
don't normally do but Tesla just have a
bit of fun with them
it's not yet like Knight Rider because
the car doesn't talk back at you you
can't have a conversation with it but
when it comes to autonomous technology
Tesla is certainly one of the leaders
out there
if people want electric cars fine but
you see through electric cars
comes what
driverless cars now when you see some of
the things that have happened with
driverless cars and you see how
computers can go wrong well you know I'm
not sure I will want to be in a
driverless car
people are quite keyed off of the whole
autonomous vehicle thing I think maybe
people have this like image of like
robot cars run amok it's really not
anything like that all of that what if I
had decipher goes through extreme levels
of validation before a customer ever
sees it so there's all sorts of nonsense
about people being used as human guinea
pigs you know it's basically Advanced
driver's assistance at this point
um in fact we use the name autopilot
because that's what that's what's used
in aircraft but the presumption in
aircraft is that the pilot must you know
pay attention to be alert and be ready
to take over any time not not that the
pilot can then go go to sleep or you
know walk away from the cockpit
musk is confronting some of the world's
biggest challenges head on through Tesla
he intends to reduce our use of fossil
fuels while simultaneously attempting to
revolutionize the energy industry
a key part of his aim is to change not
just energy consumption but energy
production
Elon is the chairman of Solar City one
of the largest producers of solar power
systems in the United States
fill in a remote Village or an island
somewhere can take solar panels combine
it with the Tesla powerwall and and
never have to worry about it having
electricity lines electricity lines are
not the most pretty thing in the world
so being able to have this solution just
works wherever you are the fact that
it's wall mounted is is vital because it
means you don't need to have a battery
room it means that a normal household
can mount this on on their garage or on
the outside wall of their house and it
doesn't take up any room you can
actually go if you want completely
off-grid you can take your solar panels
charge the battery packs and that's all
you use and the cost of this is thirty
five hundred dollars
oh wow the Grid it's actually zero
this entire night has been powered by
batteries
for the SolarCity company that's now
part of Tesla elon's trying to make
solar panels more attractive to the mass
Market they launched their new solar
roof technology whereas in the old days
solar panels would be big black bulky
squares that you'd put out on your roof
for your garden now people are going to
have solar panel was embedded into their
roof
Tesla's lithium-ion battery installed in
South Australia led to a massive drop in
the costs of backing up the Region's
power supply
the system powered by wind turbines
reduced the price of power outages by 90
percent
they are taking the Surplus electricity
that's been produced in Australia and
store and get and putting it back to the
grid I think the latest estimates
suggest they're making up to a million
dollars a day from the electricity
they're storing which is pretty
impressive that came from a bet that he
made over Twitter so it was an
Australian businessman and they were
discussing about the feasibility of
making a city run on solar power and a
bet was issued to a mosque about can you
do it in this much time and he went I'll
take that bet
put batteries in place had it up and
running within the time scale all for a
Billionaire's bet and that's what came
of it
we have reached an agreement
with Tesla Motor Company
subject to legislative review and
approval
that will enable Tesla to build the
world's largest
and most advanced battery Factory right
here in the Silver State
why do we even call it the gigafactory
it's because it's actually going to be
it's not just going to be the biggest
lithium-ion battery Factory in the world
but it'll actually be bigger than the
sum of all lithium-ion factories in the
world so it's difficult to quite
describe in words but it's a heck of a
big Factory
foreign
[Music]
launch Elon Musk has continued to make
history with SpaceX when the Falcon
heavy rockets launched in February 2018
it heralded the start of a new space
race
kind of the Super Bowl of rocket
launches
Elon Musk and his team just proved that
the Falcon heavy Works which puts us now
in a completely different realm what we
can put into deep space what we can send
to Mars
lifting off from the same launch pad
that sent the crew of Apollo 11 to the
moon the mission represented a new era
in the progress of space flight
[Music]
the launch of the SpaceX Falcon heavy
was significant for so many reasons
scientifically I mean it's the most
powerful rocket we've seen launched
since 2005 which took humans to the Moon
that's one small step for man
foreign
we are entering a new era of space
exploration which is extremely exciting
sort of the continuance of the dream of
Apollo
I was on the Space Coast after the
launch I haven't seen it that busy there
since 2011 when the space shuttle
launched and landed for the final time
it really has started to capture
people's imaginations about space
exploration
it was a great achievement by a private
company to create and successfully
launch
one of the biggest lifting Rockets ever
in history it's the third largest rocket
ever to be launched we had the Apollo
Saturn V of course we had the shuttle
the Falcon heavy is that order of
magnitude it is a seriously big rocket
the Falcon heavy can carry 64 tons
that's a lot I mean it's a truck it's
the equivalent of a 737 jetliner filled
with passengers filled with baggage
filled with fuel lifting that up and
sending it into space and not just
sending it into space sending it Beyond
low earth orbits sending it beyond the
moon sending it Beyond Mars
this launch will also have political
implications in my view because the
American government is preparing and
budgeting for NASA's Rockets but the
fact that Elon and SpaceX have now
proven they can successfully launch the
Falcon heavy which will probably have a
cost at about 100 million dollars that's
about 10 percent of the NASA Rockets So
they are purchasing about a billion
dollars per launch that's a significant
cost saving and that is what private
Enterprise can do when you put the right
person at the helm and you give them a
chance to execute his vision
in order for us to
really open up access to space we've got
to achieve a
full and rapid reusability and being
able to do that for the primary rocket
booster is going to be a huge impact on
cost now it'll still take us a few years
to make that smooth and make it
efficient but it's I think it's proven
that it can work
of all musk's Innovations developing
reusable Rockets could be the most
radical
we thought it was more likely the night
that this Mission would would work but
still probably you know went to a chance
of a failure the holy grail for space is
to have a totally reusable launch system
so to actually see the SpaceX Falcon
Rockets launching its spacecraft into
orbit and then coming back down and
performing a pinpoint accurate landing
on a floating platform at Sea that is
pretty astonishing it's quite a tiny
Target it's really trying to land on a
postage stamp there just to put it this
way you get on airplane
and you fly somewhere you wouldn't dream
of throwing that airplane away so why do
we do the same with space Rockets that's
what SpaceX is trying to do and they're
succeeding they're leading the way at
the moment elon's getting people to
question why NASA is still building any
rockets at all
they think if SpaceX can do it why do we
need to build a comparable rocket we can
just buy that one of them
inside the Falcon heavy rocket was a
plaque with 6 000 names of all the
SpaceX employees that worked on the
project
and that just shows that he's willing to
really value the people that work for
him
Elon musk's aspiration is to eventually
put all of his efforts into developing
far larger Rockets
which can still launch payloads into
Earth orbit but also be capable of
taking human rated spacecraft into deep
space I.E Mars
you have like a 10 to 20 year Horizon
here where you want to go to Mars
I want to enable uh large numbers of
people in cargo to go to Mars
so it's not sort of about me you
personally want to make a journey back
to Mars I mean that would be nice on a
personal level but I do think it is
important
um that we as a species of civilization
are on a path to become a true space for
a true space foreign civilization and a
multi-planet species
musk aims to launch a mission to Mars by
2022.
Elon musk's ultimate goal is to have
humans permanently living and working on
Mars and Martian Colony you could say
Mars is very special
as sky
and it has landscape
and large amounts of Frozen water and it
has seasons so there are a lot of
similarities to Earth
the atmosphere is much thinner than
Earth's atmosphere but you've got carbon
and then you've got oxygen so you could
potentially use what's on Mars's
atmosphere as resources it's a very
terrestrial environment it appears to be
a home from home but is it
it is possible in our lifetime to send a
rocket to Mars uh manned I I do think
that's possible
do we want to do it do we want to pay
for it that's a different question
there's a lot of questions there's a lot
of
hurdles
break the fund
Mars is reachable
and I'm sure we will devise the means by
which we can live there
but there are many questions and
challenges before that can be achieved
so let must say he's going to do it
because he probably will
maintains this momentum I see no reason
why he shouldn't be landing spacecraft
on Mars
Elon musk's involvement with design
engineering and critical technical
decisions is unique amongst his peers
believe me elon's just as smart on
engineering as he is on the money side
even in the earlier days of Tesla and
SpaceX he could easily have said let me
put in some of my cash in there and
we'll put some clever technical people
and I'll just run it I'll be the manager
I'll be the CEO or whatever to actually
be able to get so involved in the
engineering side that's amazing but
that's what he did because deep down he
is an engineer
I would say he approaches engineering
and business in much the same fashion
it's a puzzle to be dissected and then
the piece is put back together in some
way
at his heart the man is an engineer I
think that's where his first love is
that he'll be walking around SpaceX and
we'll talk to the employees and then
we'll quiz them on things like thrust
vectors or aerodynamical design not
typical CEO Behavior
I think the engineering came more
naturally because the engineering part
is a more rational approach he
sort of struggled early on in the CEO
role of his two early companies but
certainly we've seen that he just
learned and Grew From that and so I
think you know he's sort of the whole
package at this point I don't think too
many people would argue with that
some entrepreneurs are more socially
skilled than others but they're not
necessarily social skilled because
they're too focused see if you're a
socially skilled human being then you're
sensitive to everybody around you
but that may prevent you from actually
getting on to achieve your objective
and they have objectives in mind and
they are ruthless in the sense of trying
to achieve that objective not ruthless
in the way they treat other people
necessarily
just in making sure that they're on
their own timeline to achieve that
objective
[Music]
made an enormous PR mistake and it had
landed on the front page of the New York
Post
and it was bad like it was mortifyingly
bad and when I went in to tell Elon
about it you know he was very very angry
with me and the things that he said the
thing that he said that stuck with me
was Julie perception becomes reality
it was the only time that he was really
really angry with me that I can remember
and the fact that he didn't fire me I
think just points to him being a nice
guy
one of the things I find so fascinating
about Elon is that in the midst of all
of his Acumen and business sense he does
interviews where he tears up and even
cries talking about how he wants to find
the one it's not easy being Elon it
sounds amazing sounds glamorous and it
no doubt is also a lot of fun he's
having a ball executing his engineering
dreams the flip side of that coming to
the personal side It Ain't Easy
Elon started dating a very famous
celebrity actress who was at the time at
war with her ex-husband Johnny Depp like
I don't know what it is about Amber but
men who fall in love with Amber they
fall hard for Amber so everyone was very
curious in the Showbiz world to see who
Amber would end up with next and when we
saw she was at the billionaire who had
this kind of baby face there was a lot
of interest in finding out more
the breakup between Elon and Amber was
very painful for Elon and he very
characteristically I suppose is very
open with people and journalists about
how much he was hurting at one stage in
a very high profile interview he did
with rolling stone he actually asked the
journalist who's doing the story do you
know anybody you could set me up with is
there anybody you know I should date
for a billionaire guy who is like let's
be honest decently good looking to be
out there talking about how he wants to
find a nice girlfriend it's just
something you don't see come along very
often
he's fairly an open book so if they had
been spending some time together and the
journalist had earned his trust in some
capacity I it wouldn't surprise me at
all and he definitely wears his heart on
his sleeve I would say he's a big softy
underneath
I mean Elon is so honest and vulnerable
and I think that's why people find him
so incredibly endearing there are a lot
of technological dreams that Elon Musk
would have for himself over the next two
decades but I think as much as he wants
all of that I think Elon Musk would like
to be happily in love
[Music]
musk continues to invest in the future
in 2013 he outlined a potential
world-changing plan for a transportation
system that could reshape the way
Humanity travels
Elon Musk came up with the idea he
published a white paper on this vacuum
transport but let it go he said I'm not
going to do this myself what I'm going
to do is open up to third-party
companies that want to develop it
themselves with the hyperloop project is
of huge interest in terms of the world
of Transportation the idea of going from
San Francisco to Los Angeles in the time
it it would take to drive from San
Francisco to the edge of San Francisco
is fantastic it's a vacuum tube where
all the air is sucked out of the tube
and you send a pod containing passengers
through the tube there's no friction
there's no air resistance because the
pods are levitating on magnets the
technology is sound we can travel faster
in a vacuum there's no friction they
want to get up to speeds about 500 to
700 miles an hour elon's idea is that
these tubes could connect major cities
and you could travel in one of these
passenger pods and travel from say LA to
New York in a matter of half an hour
when he was talking about the first time
we we all thought over this time we
might have you might have lost it a
little bit or is a little bit too
ambitious or too crazy
but as with many other villains ideas
watch that space because before you know
it and actually head up schedule this
thing is actually becoming reality
Let's see we can put these tunnels out
is dramatic how fast it can all happen
so I think a lot a lot of the world will
be connected
we will be moving Cargo in 2019. we
think we can have passengers safely
being transported in hyperloop by 2021
Elon Musk is a leading voice on the
potential of an AI apocalypse he has
declared that digital super intelligence
is the most serious threat to the
survival of the human race
to offset this he launched nerolink
aimed at developing safe and beneficial
artificial intelligence
the dangers of AI are the end of the
human mind as we know it you're dealing
with something that's fundamentally
going to be smarter than you it's going
to learn on its own so how do you stay
ahead of it that's something that musk
is paying close attention to his main
concern is that if AIA becomes too smart
and too important then why do you need
humans we kind of become obsolete
the very worst nightmare
that our Hollywood horror movie could
ever come up with is as nothing
compared with where we're heading and
heading so fast
when AI has the ability to think
to come to conclusions and to make
judgments
Etc just like the human mind does anyone
think there might be just the slightest
chance
that through that alone
AI could take the planet over
[Music]
if they do become self-aware how are we
going to control them who's going to
control the controllers it's a scary
Prospect
what is its potential to take over
everything you know what it's potential
to take over everything is 100
it's the end of humanity when software
Rises up and becomes all-powerful where
are we going to look to we're going to
look to the titans of Industry to
provide a counterweight elon's ideally
placed to be the the sort of
CounterPoint to this software only
Vision I mean it's interesting that he's
also looking into AI himself with open
Ai and neurolink
when I hear Elon Musk talking about the
fact that AI Revolution is Humanity
summoning the demon absolutely it is
but then um founding and opening a
company called neuralink to connect AI
to the human brain I mean that
contradiction is so extraordinary I
don't know the thought processes that
must be going on there
neurolink is a direct response of elon's
concerns to AI in the first place the
fact that he thinks AI might surpass
humans in terms of its mental
capabilities it makes sense that he
would try and develop technology using
computers in tandem with our biology
I think that Elon Musk who wants to use
AI as a tool for
augmenting ourselves
and not a tool for replacing ourselves I
think he's saying we can't beat them
become superhuman and then beat them
brain computer interfaces could help
people in two different ways so one way
would be to restore capabilities for
people with disabilities and another
application would be to go beyond our
limitation and so for example we could
think about controlling a computer just
with our thoughts without moving any
muscle and that's the core function of a
BCI a brain computer interface there are
a lot of different scenarios in which
you could apply this technology we're
talking about critical decision making
in the military in a Warfare scenario or
in a health sector so whenever we talk
about hybrid humans or human machine or
or cyborgs we are all talking about the
same thing I think which is using
technology to augment our capabilities
and that's it
musk's skepticism about the potential
risks of AI technology has led to a
public clash with Mark Zuckerberg
I'm optimistic about the future of AI I
think that AI is going to unlock a huge
amount of positive things whether that's
helping to identify and cure diseases to
help cars drive more safely to help keep
our communities safe are there going to
be issues along the way of course there
are no technology comes out fully formed
and we need the Pioneers to be able to
go work on this get to the state that we
want
I do think it's very healthy that we
have such
technology Giants fighting it up
publicly so that we can all form an
opinion about it it's a spectator sport
now for the rest of us Mark Zuckerberg
sees Elon as a naysayer and someone
who's trying to stop the development of
AI
I can see both sides of the argument I'd
probably side slightly with Mark
Zuckerberg in the sense that I think we
will be able to control AI enough to
keep Humanity safe I wouldn't bet
against Elon you know if Elon thinks
that AI is going to take over and
eventually decide that us irrational
humans are unnecessary I would trust him
you know he hasn't been wrong about a
lot the debate is either it's a good
thing we must do it it's a bad thing but
we still must do it in another way
we should stop doing it immediately
before the line is crossed where
humanity is no more we need policies we
need to start thinking what is a good
application of BCI and what is not
we need to be the one with the control
being able to push a button and disable
the AI at any moment
however rather than replacing humans I
prefer to see us working together we
both bring unique skills and talents to
the table
there's going to be a difference between
what's doable and what's acceptable and
this is something that Elon is not going
to decide this is something that Mark
Zuckerberg's not going to decide
this is you and I and everybody else and
hopefully that will be translated
eventually into legislation
Elon musk's assertion that we're likely
to be living in a simulated reality has
popularized a theory debated by
philosophers and now gaining supporters
in Silicon Valley Elon Musk has said
that we're living in some kind of
computer 3D simulation I don't know if
that means we're in The Matrix or some
kind of a matrix and you know as as
bizarre and craziest that sounds Elon
has been saying bizarre in crazy things
that turned out to be true for a long
time now so I would say
um maybe well you never know do you well
disprove it we can't disprove it we
could be of lower intelligence and there
could be another species far far more
intelligent than us
and they're almost playing God With Us
sounds ridiculous to say something like
that but we don't know much we've barely
left our own Plano
I felt like what he was seeing was that
this is not base reality and so I would
agree with him on that front do you get
labeled crazy because you're pushing the
boundaries of what people expect
he's coming at it from a scientific
perspective but that idea that there's
only one true reality and this isn't it
is actually the underpinnings of all the
ancient religions of the world all of
those point to exactly the same thing
that he's saying so
I'm with him
I've been saying in my books
for a lot longer than Elon Musk that we
live in the equivalent of a massively
Advanced virtual reality computer game
in the end
and when you look
at the evidence it is
overwhelming certainly immensely
compelling
and this is why not just Elon Musk many
scientists now are coming out and saying
actually it does look like that
ultimately for me it seems to be a bit
of an improvable Theory I mean how are
we going to prove that we're living in a
in a simulation I don't know don't
discount his his wack of ideas because
suddenly they do pop up in one shape or
another
um but I'm not sure about that one I
think we have to see more meat on the
bone on that one I just think it's
interesting that musk is able to put
something like that out there and show
that what others might consider a bit of
a ridiculous thought or might be worried
about being ridiculed for he's actually
giving serious thought to I think what
musk is always looking to do is to
foster a discussion
inspired by frustrations of sitting in a
traffic jam musk's solution was the
boring company in 2018 the company was
selected to build a high-speed
underground transportation system in
Chicago
I'd like to thank the mayor and the
mayor's office and the City of Chicago
for having the faith to to bet on the
boring company
uh we think we're going to really be
very good at boring you could almost say
that Elon has the Midas touch because
when he started the boring company which
is really about boring under the Earth
as opposed to being dull he actually
started selling baseball caps online
before he did anything else and
literally made a million dollars you
know this is a guy who everything he
touches turns to Gold he's kept us all
interested because he's started tweeting
out offers of hats and flamethrowers
we're all interested to see what's going
to happen with it this is a difficult
thing that we're doing it's it's a hard
thing it's a new thing and
you know I'd hope that uh you cheer us
on for this you know because if we
succeed it's going to be a great thing
for the city and if we if we fail well I
guess me and others will lose a bunch of
money
Elon Musk is one of the great
engineering minds of our time
he was one of the great Business Leaders
and entrepreneurs of our time and he's
one of the great Visionaries of our time
elong will be remembered as one of the
guys who was unafraid to say what else
I think his greatest achievement is
inspiring Humanity to think bigger to
dream bigger in a world where there's so
many problems isn't it nice to have a
positive story occasionally we're all
just sort of sitting back and watching
what's going to come out next
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]